avec alexis poulain éditorialiste
politique
avec ses poulains mère bonjour merci
d'être en doute avec nous voilà une
décision de justice qui intervient en
plein coeur de la rentrée quelles
conséquences ce qu'elle discrédite d'une
certaine manière la politique de santé
du gouvernement
elle ne discrédite pas mais elle va
permettre d'avoir des informations sur
cette politique de santé puisque
évidemment depuis le début il ya eu des
mensonges des non-dits beaucoup de ratés
or emmanuel macron a choisi de gérer ça
de manière opaque via des conseils de
défense tenue au secret défense de
manière autocratique également entourées
d'un aéropage un d'experts choisis triés
sur le volet or si la démocratie et les
contre-pouvoirs fonctionné on aurait
déjà eu bien sûr des explications on en
a eu d'ailleurs agnès buzyn était venu
s'expliquer devant le parlement mais
face à une majorité la république en
marche évidemment elle s'en était sorti
sans trop de questions qui fâchent il
faut que la justice entre en jeu pour
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé dans
cette gestion sanitaire qui a été
calamiteuse à rappelez-vous agnès buzyn
c'est elle qui déclarait dès le début
que le virus ne circulerait pas en
france qui mettait des petites affiches
à l'aéroport de paris pour que le virus
ne viennent pas ensuite elle a menti sur
les masques et puis elle est partie elle
a démissionné en laissant sa place à
olivier ferrand pour faire campagne pour
la mairie de paris en pleine crise de
pandémie alors même qu'elle avait dit à
l'époque qu'elle savait que le pire
était à venir ça pose des questions à la
fois sur la façon dont sept ministres a
géré la crise ses liens avec bien sûr
son mari et l'ouverture de ce
laboratoire p4 à hawan en chine qui
reste encore une question sur l'origine
du virus ou non de ce laboratoire et et
beaucoup de choses sur ensuite la
gestion de cette crise alors évidemment
elle est la première à répondre à la
justice pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui pour aussi refus abstention
volontaire de combattre un sinistre mais
il y à d'autres plaintes qui courent
notamment contre edouard philippe
olivier ferrand notamment autre ministre
de la santé il y avait des perquisitions
rappelez-vous chez ces responsables
politiques donc il faut que la justice
entre en jeu pour que les français aient
enfin des réponses aux questions qu'ils
se posent sur cette gestion l'étrange si
ce n'est calamiteuse de la alors c'est
peut-être la première fois dans le monde
d'ailleurs qu'un cas ministre est mise
en cause légalement en tout cas pour sa
gestion de la pandémie et vous citiez un
certain nombre de personnes est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut s'attendre à un
effet dominos justement sur la classe
politique
peut-être ouverture une sorte de boîte
de pandore
alors on voit bien que au sein de la
majorité oui il ya une certaine
fébrilité voire une peur que ce soit un
premier domino qui tombe et qui emmène
d'autres notamment olivier ferrand ou
edouard philippe emmanuel macron
évidemment qui est président de la
république c'est comme si finalement les
responsables politiques découvrait
qu'avec la fonction publique la fonction
politique celle de gérer un ministère je
dirais le l'intérêt commun il y avait
des responsabilités
or évidemment avec cette course justice
de la république on se rappelle tous
sein de l' affaire du sang contaminé qui
avait fini par un responsable mais pas
coupable et on se dit qu'il ya un
précédent et un ministre ne risque pas
grand chose face à cette cour de justice
de la république puisque laurent fabius
qui avait été jugé dans la sphère du
sang contaminé se retrouve aujourd'hui à
la tête du conseil d'état au conseil
constitutionnel je ne sais plus excusez
moi mais voilà la question qui se pose
finalement c'est celle de la
responsabilité politique et juridique
alors dans le juridique évidemment on ne
va pas mettre agnès buzyn en prison au
pénal mais elle doit répondre de la
façon dont son ministère a fonctionné et
elle est donc responsable il n'y a
aucune raison de vouloir se soustraire
de ses responsabilités comme le font à
longueur de temps et politique disant
que c'est inacceptable qu'on ne trouvera
plus de ministres parce que si vous êtes
ministre et que vous êtes responsable
plus personne ne voudra faire ce boulot
là non c'est un boulot qui doit être
toujours sous la responsabilité la
façon dont les français regardent et non
pas un boulot qui permet les
responsabilités comme comme on le voit
puisque c'est avec une certaine légèreté
que agnès buzyn est parti faire campagne
pour la mairie de paris elle a perdu
bien entendu en cours de route et puis
ensuite elle a été gentiment recruté par
l'om s
retrouvant là un poste qui lui permet de
continuer de travailler dans le domaine
de la santé qu'elle connaît dire sans
jamais avoir à rendre de compte donc
heureusement encore une fois que la
justice est là et si on regarde la façon
dont la reconstitution est fait et bien
il devrait y avoir des mandats
révocatoire pour les élus parce que ils
doivent rendre des comptes
systématiquement dernière question on
est à quelques mois de la présidentielle
est ce que cette mise en examen a de
quoi sérieusement inquiéter la majorité
manuel macro alors elle oui c'est une
inquiétude notamment du côté de
d'edouard philippe à inquiéter l'ancien
promu liste pourrait mener le maquereau
il est président de la république donc
ce sera extrêmement difficile de
remonter jusqu'à lui il s'est d'ailleurs
protéger via ses conseils de défense
comme je le disais puisque tout a été le
choisit organisés pour être sous le
sceau du secret défense permettant une
opacité totale face aux demandes de la
justice donc la majorité peut craindre
alors un déficit d'image puisqu'on va
remettre sur la table cette gestion
calamiteuse alors qu'ils menaient le
maquereau me faire croire qu'il a été le
meilleur du monde pour gérer l'épidémie
de kobe d' en france donc on va creuser
davantage sur les mensonges à répétition
notamment d'années ce bizarre mais aussi
d'odile et veyran a rappelé vous qu'ils
disaient également que le masque ne
servait à rien au tout début de sa prise
de fonction qui a changé dix fois d'avis
et qui maintenant majorité qui nous fait
vivre sous un état d'exception permanent
un état d'urgence permanent avec ce pass
sanitaires à critiquer encore une
manifestation aujourd'hui contre se
passe delà de la honte comme certains
l'appellent donc oui il va falloir
rendre des comptes il va falloir
continuer c'est une bonne chose que la
justice soit aussi rapide pour que les
français aient enfin en réponse à leurs
questions merci beaucoup en tout cas
alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste politique